okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's an abysmal issen hi David um I
just want to ask you a quick question
regards to taxes so I'm currently a
small business owner and I have been
living around her I previously lived
around five years on near poverty
building our business and I come out
here liberals saying that they want to
tax businesses and people who are
successful because businesses you know
at seven percent of while these are
their high tax rates which I I would
fall into any not all of them but a good
portion of so and I've not taken time
from government so why do I have to pay
Todd this huge amount in taxes I feel
like it's a little bit ridiculous
especially since I've lived it so many
years and poverty just don't like this
Thanks yeah listen you don't have to pay
the taxes right you pay taxes on
business profit if you are building a
business and your business grosses a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year and you have a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars a year in expenses and
you come out earning twenty thousand
dollars a year if it's a sole
proprietorship you're barely paying
taxes on that because you're you you you
only profited twenty thousand dollars if
it's an S corporation or an LLC it's
passed through income and it's only
twenty thousand dollars of income so
you're nobody is suggesting that
businesses that are not turning a profit
and leaving their owners in near poverty
as the caller says they're not going to
have to pay any kind of higher income
tax rate whether the income tax rate on
corporations is thirty five percent or
twenty one percent if you have a sole
proprietorship and you're not making any
money number one you're not taxed at the
corporate rate your tax that the
personal rate and number two you're only
taxed on the actual profit if your
business expenses are significant
you're not paying the taxes okay so
you've got to understand how the tax
code works nobody is saying that you
because you are building this business
and are almost not profiting at all need
to be paying more taxes nobody is
proposing that I've not seen that that's
not what the law is looking to do if you
look at Democratic proposals period so
you got to understand how this entire
thing works we've got a great bonus show
for you today I'm out of time I hope you
will join me I know a lot of our new
members will absolutely be there
listening to or watching today's bonus
show